all right one more time we're now
looking at a framework to help us as we
try to market our products this is the
Accord framework use it when you're
designing your new product the Accord
framework helps us to predict which
product or products will quote cross the
chasm from the early adopters in the
market to the early and late majority
and then finally the late adopters it's
an acronym that stands for advantage
compatibility complexity observability
risk and divisibility we need to
maximize advantage compatibility
observability and divisibility and
minimize complexity and risk a court is
useful
anytime you design a product because it
gives you the levers that will help
determine the products adoption it can
also help you understand why a product
may have failed although it doesn't give
you precise guidelines of how much each
factor matters it can give you an
overall sense of how your product will
do or why your product succeeded or
failed in the past when YouTube first
launched there was another site called
metacafe in which people could post
video content essentially Metacafe was
YouTube before YouTube was YouTube so
why did YouTube succeed in Metacafe
eventually fail we can't know for a fact
but the Accord framework helps us
understand the likely reason in order to
view video content on Metacafe a user
had to either go to the site or download
a video player in contrast YouTube made
things less complex and more compatible
if you wanted to share a video you could
simply share the embed code in an email
the recipient would click and voila out
would come the video so YouTube made it
easier and less complicated to share the
content than metacafe the rest is
history
Google purchased YouTube for over 1.6
billion dollars and nowadays YouTube is
a major revenue generator for Google
another example is satellite radio when
Sirius first launched satellite radio
was a standalone device that had to be
installed on a car dashboard the
installation included drilling a hole in
the car's roof too common in an antenna
initial sales were quite slow and the
Accord framework helps us understand why
the product suffered from two major
problems the first one is in
compatibility
if I have to drill a hole in my car the
device is hardly compatible the second
problem relates to risk buyers had to
rely on an unproven service the
dependent on really expensive satellites
I could spend a good amount of money
installing a device then maybe I
couldn't use so when did satellite radio
really take off
when Sirius radios began to be
integrated to the existing car radio the
company increased compatibility and
reduced a perception of risk after all
if my car comes with a device already
implanted it seems like a less risky
proposition